une rentrée scolaire un peu particulière
pour les écoliers de la verrière les 173
élèves de l'école élémentaire du bois de
l'étang se sont rendus ce matin devant
leur établissement incendié pendant les
émeutes enfant et famille ont été
accueillis par le maire de la ville
Nicolas Dainville et la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse
malgré l'émotion tout est mis en place
pour que cette rentrée soit une réussite
ça a été beaucoup de boulot il a fallu
faire venir du mobilier spécifique pour
les enfants il a fallu harmoniser les
tarifs de cantine c'est la région qui
payera la différence de tarifs entre le
lycée et le primaire il a fallu mettre
en place les navettes des navettes
évidemment gratuites que
Île-de-France mobilité prend en charge
donc c'est un effort financier mais
c'est surtout voilà le fruit d'un
travail collectif pour bien accueillir
ses enfants cette rentrée et que les
émeutiers n'est pas gagné des ce matin
d'écart gratuit ont été mis à
disposition des élèves direction l'école
régionale du 1er degré le nouvel
établissement des enfants un changement
d'organisation mais surtout un
soulagement pour les familles
un peu particulière mais bon comme je
disais tout à l'heure on sera adapte
c'est un peu difficile pour les enfants
mais
voilà quoi les enfants vont prendre un
rythme un peu spécial parce que c'est
vrai que au bois de l'étang on va quand
il allait à l'école ils se réveillait un
peu plus tard là du fait ils vont se
réveiller un peu plus tôt nous on
n'était pas loin de ce qui s'était passé
c'était un peu compliqué au final ça
serait règle c'est particulier la
rentrée j'ai entendu qu'il y avait des
écoles qui pouvaient pas rouvrir
donc j'imagine pas j'imagine même pas
comment les parents doivent être et pour
organiser cette rentrée les équipes
étaient sur le pied de guerre cet été
pour pouvoir accueillir les élèves dans
les meilleures conditions il y a
quelques jours ces derniers ont pu
visiter leur nouvelle établissement avec
leurs parents en compagnie de l'équipe
pédagogique une manière de mieux
appréhender cette rentrée
ça change après deux mois deux travaux
acharnés tout est désormais prêt pour
les nouveaux arrivants les équipes
municipales ont été exceptionnelles nos
partenaires ont été
si précieux pour tout arranger pour tout
aménager pour tout finaliser à temps et
pour réaliser une prouesse accueillir
dans cette école régionale de 1er degré
près de 180 enfants en aménageant cette
nouvelle salle de classe ce qui n'est
pas rien en réglant les soucis de
navette pour amener les enfants de
cantine d'accueil donc
on est très satisfait et satisfait les
parents le sont aussi pour moi oui ça va
ils ont bien aménagé les locaux et ça me
convient cette école c'est magnifique
c'est joli par rapport à l'autre l'école
de bas de l'étang cette cohabitation
entre les deux groupes scolaires
devraient durer au moins trois ans le
temps nécessaire à la reconstruction de
l'école du bois de l'ét ang